let me start with uh congratulations i
am uh a huge fan of the matrix in the
matrix movies and it's awesome to talk
to you guys about it
i am curious on what day of the shoot
did you both have like that moment where
you're looking around and you sort of
are taking in what you're doing and what
you're a part of and realize how special
like the moment was
i have a
moment in the film where i'm sitting and
i got to observe
uh
keanu and carrie anne together
uh and and seeing them
as one was really kind of uh wow this is
this is a real thing that's happening
because otherwise i was mostly just with
keanu as his analyst talking with him in
a real world setting and so that felt
like we could be making an indie film
you know a scene from sense8 or
something cool uh but then when i was in
that moment on a sound stage i do
believe
wow
this is happening and it's very real
that was cool
i well the first time i walked into the
training tent
and i saw keanu in his like
jiu jitsu outfit
kicking
punching
sweating
and then at the same time kyrianne
was fighting off at least 15 to 20
people
doing like the ha ha ha ha they were
like running through her giant sequence
and i got out of the van that was my
first day there and i thought oh whoa
this is for real this is the matrix this
is crazy
oh wow uh
i i can't even imagine i'm a huge fan of
lana uh i just love i'm a big fan and
i'm curious if you could talk a little
bit about working with her and maybe
what surprised you when you were on set
that perhaps you weren't expecting
i was not expecting her to be the single
point of everything
and i
i'm surprised at that but i just assumed
with a movie of this budget of this
scale with these expectations that big
sequences on the streets of san
francisco at one o'clock in the morning
with helicopters and hundreds of extras
there would be
a team of people right with storyboard
drawings of everything that they are
going to film and animatics of scenes so
that they've already shot it and they're
just they're just checking things off a
list and in turn it was lana wachowski
just looking at some monitors pondering
and the first assistant director with a
mic saying uh walkie-talkie what are we
doing what
hold on a second hold on lana
and she just thinks and she says okay we
need this and this and we'll do that and
we'll do this and we need this and this
and then i go and i was like
is anyone like how is this happening for
this giant sequence that was her the
whole movie she's done this movie three
times before not this one but these
sequences she knows intrinsically what
she wants and what she needs and
everyone listens to her so
that was most impressive to me that it
all existed here and she kept it close
and and everything that she wanted she
got from everyone so cool to be a part
of
i was surprised that that
she
she talks about her creative process
that 20 years ago
it was
very pre-planned very controlled very
thought out and then over the last 20
years it's she's done a total 180 and
now she likes to be surprised
but the level to which
she she wants us all on
sort of shifting ground i thought it
would be like this is who your character
is this is how i want you to say this
line when we get to this point i want
you to do this
and she has extreme point of view and
extreme control like neil was saying but
at the same time she's really living
for
the unplanned
moments she's living to capture the
adrenaline and the surprise
even though she has the lore she's got
insane intelligence she knows this world
so much when it came to the acting beat
to beat she would change something she
would rewrite a line she would move you
around she would see the sun coming in
from somewhere else and change the
entire setup to capture what she was
seeing as artful in the moment and so
that spontaneity like extreme commitment
to spontaneity was
shocking and thrilling i have to wrap
i'm just going to say to both of you i
really do hope one day i can talk to
both of you about specifics in this
movie because it kills me to not be
talking about this
movie
yes a fantastic day thank you so much
thank you